today i want to teach you a little bit
about significant figures now to
understand why these are important
before we get to some practical tips on
how to work out significant figures i'm
going to ask you a simple question which
is what is the population of australia
now it's about 25 million but i think
you can know even without sort of
knowing the statistics off the top of
your head that that's not a precise
number however even though it's not
precise it's close enough for practical
purposes and i can think of at least two
reasons for that number one it allows us
to do meaningful comparisons we can say
all right 25 million is the population
of australia
332 million is the population of the
united states of america so it's like
okay i've got now a ballpark figure for
how big one is in relation to the other
and i don't need so you know very fine
down to a single or tens of people um
just the number of millions is close
enough and secondly it's actually
impossible to maintain precise
up-to-date data on something like the
population of a country we have a census
every now and then but even as soon as
you do a census which is actually
precise that information immediately
goes out of date because it takes a
while to tabulate all that information
from across the country and then once
you've done that well the population has
changed so therefore saying about 25
million it actually makes sense now
this kind of data here like the
population of a country it's a quantity
that's counted
often what we call this is discrete data
because when you count something you end
up with whole numbers and that's what
discrete numbers are sort of like the
whole numbers and integers and so on
but actually even when you are not
counting something if you are say
measuring a quantity and we would say
that that's continuous data it's still
useful to actually do this rounding off
or approximation let me give you a
concrete example
very recently i painted the inside of my
house now you can imagine before you
start painting a house it's pretty
useful to have a rough idea of how much
area you're going to need to cover so
like how much are all the walls how much
of the ceilings and so on
but for the same like similar reasons as
to before just sort of rounding off the
area that you calculate actually makes
sense for example when you're actually
measuring out say this wall that you're
looking at here which is not in my house
but if you were measuring it and the
actual you know tape measure or ruler
that you are using could only measure to
the nearest centimeter then it wouldn't
really make sense to actually provide
your answer for the total area of this
wall in terms of square millimeters you
just don't have that kind of accuracy
with the things the instruments that
you're using to measure and then
secondly if you have a think about you
know once you've got this all totaled up
say you worked out that it was somewhere
between 30.4 square meters and 30.5
square meters it's like well is that
level of accuracy of one damp smaller
place is that meaningful and the answer
is in this case probably not
one liter of paint it covers about 12
square meters so whether you're like
30.4 square meters or 30.5 square meters
you're still going to need
three tubs of one liter of paint so
therefore for practical purposes the
approximation of saying 30 meters or 30
even 31 square meters is totally fine
and that level accuracy kind of depends
on the kind of problem you're going to
solve
and so this leads us to the idea that
for most numbers we encounter in
everyday life like i said before these
are the counted ones and we would call
these measured
so they are also called continuous
data or quantities
in in terms of everyday life
approximation like this is is a very
reasonable thing to do and it actually
helps us not get bogged down in
unimportant details and significant
figures are a way to do that their way
of saying okay when it comes to a
population you know what i only need to
know the number of millions the number
of say
hundreds or tens is not that important
or when it comes to the
area that i'm having to paint you know
what to the nearest square meter is just
fine i don't need to know to the nearest
square centimeter or near a square
millimeter so now that you know sort of
roughly how significant figures are
important and why they're valuable let's
actually have a think about how to
practically calculate them if you have a
number like 58 374 how are we going to
round that off to and let's just do a
couple of examples here one significant
figure or two significant figures so the
first thing to do if we just make this
part a is to think about your number in
this case it's 58
374
and in order to work out which figures
are the most significant we need to
count from one side and the question you
should ask yourself is which side is the
most significant you've got units tens
hundreds thousands and tens of thousands
so because of the way the place value
works it's always going to be the
leftmost digits that are the most
significant because they're the biggest
numbers tens of thousands and thousands
are bigger than units and tens and so on
and of course this would also be the
case if we had decimal places going off
after here
so if we have a think about this right
if we just want one significant
significant figure
then that would be in the tens of
thousands and it's either going to be
like what are the closest number of tens
of thousands to this number and the
answer is there's one above it which is
60 000 and there's one beneath it which
is 50 000. so we really just have to
pick which one of these is the two
now you may be able to just look at this
right away and say oh i know which one
it is and that's totally fine but if
you're sort of struggling along and
you've had to go at some of these
questions you're like actually i would
love a strategy to explain why beyond
like just a simple rule that i can just
memorize why is one answer the correct
one and the other one is not
well i think a really useful tool here
is going to be a number line if we can
take fifty thousand and sixty thousand
and place them on a number line i think
that makes it obvious which one of those
numbers we are closer to because you can
actually just see it visually and not
have to worry about the arithmetic of it
right so if i draw for ourselves uh a
sort of very rough number line here
and i'm going to have 50 000 on one end
and 60 000 on the other
in order to work out which one i am
closer to sometimes it helps to put a
midpoint in so i'm just going to mark
this in in blue somewhere about here
halfway between fifty thousand and sixty
thousand is fifty five thousand so this
is the midpoint now the reason why it's
useful is because if i can work out
whether i'm above or below the midpoint
that clearly nudges me towards the 50
000 or the 60 000 depending on which one
i am closer to
in this case if i think about where does
58 374 lie
it's going to be in the 58 000 which is
clearly above 55 000. so if i marked in
you know somewhere like here
this spot right here if that's 58
374 then a quick comparison shows us
that in order to get from here to 60 000
that's actually going to be a much
smaller gap compared to if i went all
the way down to 50 000. so that's why i
would say in this case the
number 58 374 to one significant figure
is 60 000 because that's the closest
number that i can get to
only having one of these digits be not
zero so that's the significant figure
right there it's it's the six now where
does the six come from it comes from
that five which rounds up because of the
eight that comes after it okay
so that's the rough idea let's just do
another further example to see how this
goes if we are to go to more significant
figures
so again if i look at that number 58
374 the question in this case is just
asking us to go one more step two
significant figures again because of
place value i'm always going to start
from the left because those are the
largest numbers the most significant
figures as it were so therefore in this
case two of them is going to be the five
and the eight so i'm in the thousands so
when i think about the thousands i'm
either going to go up to 59 000
or the other one on the other side is 58
000. and i'm just going to use the same
strategy that i used before in fact i'm
even going to sort of grab this number
line in here
that'll do me
and a few other extra bits that i don't
need at least not yet so what are my
numbers above and below i've got 58 000
over here
and then i've got 59 000 up above and
like i did before the midpoint is going
to be really helpful for me so you can
see in this case it's going to be 58
500 and by the way there's sort of a
common thing here when you think about
the midpoint it's really just the lower
number and then you're going to add 5 in
the place value after whatever your
significant figure is so you can see
here 58 000 and then the next number is
in the hundreds so that's why it's 58
500. okay so now where does 58
374 lie well you can see that 374 is
going to be beneath the 500 so therefore
again when i put in roughly where is
that number going to be i think it's
somewhere around here
that's where 58
374 will be on this number line so which
way am i going to round well it looks to
me like the easiest way the shortest
distance is over here to the left with
58 000. if i were to go all the way over
to 59 000 that is clearly a larger
distance so that's not the right answer
in this case it's 58 000 to two
significant figures
so when you have think about which way
you're going to go i think this number
line really helps and it is much the
same process if you are doing things
when you are rounding off with decimal
places so just as a quick example i
haven't written this one but if i had a
number like
say example 2
0.00056
actually i had i started with a 5 before
let's choose another number how about 3
[Music]
6 1
2. so if we have a think about this
right what is one significant figure in
this case well i'm going to go again
like i did before from the left and i'm
going to say well these are all zeros
right in much the same way that these
zeros over here are not significant
these zeros aren't either they don't
tell me anything about the size of the
number in terms of the actual you know
non-zero
size of it the magnitude of it
but here i hit a three now this is
tenths hundredths thousandths and then
i'm up to ten thousandths so this is the
most significant figure and i can see
it's either going to become
0.0004
or
0.0003
now even though i really like this
number line sort of strategy it very
obviously sort of demonstrates which one
is the
smaller or larger distance and therefore
which should you round off to um it's
it's slow isn't it like drawing out a
number line is not an efficient strategy
even if it is a clear strategy so
therefore when you have a think about
this a quicker way to work this out and
maybe you've encountered this rule
before is to have a look at the
significant figures you're actually
including and then say okay just look at
that next one right there is it going to
round up or is it going to round down we
know that by convention 5 6 7 8 9 they
round up
and then 0 1 2 3 and 4 they round down
so therefore because this is a 6 it's
going to be rounding up towards 0.0004
if on the other hand we said okay what
if i wanted two significant figures in
this case i would be saying all right
it's not just the three it's also the
six so i can just look at the next digit
after that's not
included it's a one that's going to
round down so this number to two
significant figures would be
in between these are my two choices
0.00036
or
0.00037 it's either going to stay the
same or go up
it's clearly going to be 0 0 0 3 6
because the 1 2 rounds down closer then
it rounds up
so
there's my summary for you think about
why these significant figures matter
it's because whether you're counting a
number or whether you're measuring often
it's actually very helpful to think
about well which of these numbers really
matters um you know if i need to count
down to the individual for certain
purposes that's fine but if i'm just
comparing or just trying to get a rough
idea i think for a population
in a country to the million is close
enough for countries of sizes like
australia
and then you want to think about okay
well for something like when you're
measuring out the area of a wall it's
not so obvious you actually have to make
a decision about what the right accuracy
is and that depends on say for example
how precise you need to be with how much
paint you're buying if you're going to
get a leader and it will cover 12 square
meters then that gives you a sense for
how accurate you need to be and you can
compare that with your measuring
instrument as well
it's one of the things i like about
significant figures rather than rounding
to a given number of decimal places
because in real life we often don't know
beforehand what the right number of
decimal places is if i gave you a number
like this and i said round to the
nearest one decimal place well this is
just going to be zero
however for certain things like the
concentration of chemicals in a
substance it might be very important to
go to the first second third or even the
fourth or fifth decimal place and the
way you can know is because of the size
of the number and that's something which
is best judged once you actually know
what the number is so significant
figures hugely useful and i hope these
kinds of i hope these kinds of
strategies will help you calculate them
accurately